and now it's time for bumming reviews
and if Chester a bum
tonight's review Disney's I'm late I'm
late for a very important spoilers I
assume what movie I was going to see
today and they were like Disney's Alice
in Wonderland and I'm gonna go boy I
love that cartoon with a little girl who
walks around all those weird things are
flying out of her that's my world 24/7
so I say Jenna I'm really excited to see
this movie and I'm like where's the
little girl than the movies like she's
the 19 year old over there
that's not very little and I'm like
where's Wonderland and they're like oh
it's not Wonderland anymore it's under
that sounds like if we do the loop ready
and I'm like where's all the crazy
characters and that is the storyline and
the movie says they're part of an
underground resistance because
everything is taken over and there's a
lot of action scenes concern a worry
about everything but it does have all
the weird zany stuff that's flying out
at you you have a smiling cat Queen 22
you're dumb who look like Pugsley Addams
if he was a skinhead and crazy animals I
can talk all the time it was the most
realistic movie I've ever seen in my
life probably not the most realistic
you've ever seen but you're not on drugs
johannah's goes to the mad hatter who's
part of an underground resistance and
looks like the Joker if he worked at TGI
Fridays and he's like the only way to
stop the Queen is for you to destroy the
Jabberwocky but why because this magical
piece of toilet paper said to do birdie
- guys wait the Red Queen took over
everything because she had a monster
fire side and the two playing cards
really that's it
I mean the other side has a kid that can
disappear or fly and shit shift couldn't
he just nigga find the Queen to be like
in the story and one of those tanks that
turn you into giant it's gotta just get
all that citizens around to be like
we're taking down the Queen just eat
some of these oh look out giant baby
number Queen that wasn't so hard
but no only analyst can destroy the
Jabberwocky s she gets on her armor and
looks like Joan of Noah's Ark what's she
gonna do you sir coming knowledge or
their backward ways of defeating them
new concepts have often trickle down the
stairs you know for kids so everybody's
happy because the White Queen had put
back to power again
Whitey's always seizing power and
control trying to keep the red folk down
and the man hater is so happy about this
turn of events then he actually does up
right dad do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do
do-do-do-do-do no they have breakdancing
in wonder yes be like Japan nice tree
all our style after we steal their
technology they change so I really like
this movie even though they put a story
in the story that shouldn't have a story
but I have weird things flying at me and
that's all I needed
we'll live maybe break dancing bats and
Johanna Johanna it's your birthday it's
your birthday this is just insane
it was their video game based on this
idea it was done by a guy named America
me cheese
you